[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti e benvenuti è davvero
un piacere essere qui di fronte a voi e
vi assicuro è una forte emozione perché
come ha detto marco io oggi sono da
questa parte del palco ma fino a ieri
ero dalla parte di là era uno solo uno
degli organizzatori del 3d la mia città
treviso in particolare sono modelli
responsabili della selezione degli
speaker e vi assicuro che oggi avevano
fatto veramente un ottimo lavoro
selezionare degli speaker chi vi daranno
dei messaggi veramente importanti e che
vi aiuteranno ad essere e tornare a casa
molto ispirati di oggi vi racconto una
storia la mia storia
qui vedete un po di affiliazioni delle
società per le quali che ho fondato e
per le quali ho lavorato io sono un
biotecnologo e diciamo portato avanti il
mio percorso a partire da una missione
molto importante questa missione
mi ha accompagnato in tutto il mio
percorso dalla dalle scuole fino alle
società che ho fondato le società per le
quali ho lavorato
e questa missione si focalizza su un
tema molto semplice che quello di
cercare di migliorare la salute delle
persone tramite la tecnologia il mio
percorso in auto da qui questo sono io
il primo giorno delle elementari e i
miei ricordi di quel periodo sono legati
ovviamente tutta la parte dei giochi del
divertimento
ma la parte che poi mi sono portato
avanti perché adesso la mia vita è
legata a ciò che mio padre mi ha passato
quando ero piccolo lui lasciava sparsi
per casa tutta una serie di riviste
scientifiche quelle più popolari focus
sulle scienze e quando ero piccolo io ho
cominciato a sfogliarle per meno periodo
elementari cominciavo a leggerle con lui
e questo veramente mi ha dato una forte
passione per tutto quello che è la
scienza tutto per quello che è per la
tecnologia
il percorso poi è continuato e questo è
il libro che mi ha cambiato la vita
si chiama jean egoista di richard king
che è un grandissimo scienziato un
esperto di genetica che ha scritto
questo libro sulla genomica la genomica
e la scienza di come il dna influenzi le
nostre vite influenze soprattutto la
nostra salute
questo mi ha portato a fare un percorso
accademico
un po variegato tra l'italia mi sono
laureato in biotecnologie all'università
di padova
poi ho preso una borsa di studio sono
andato a san diego all'università della
california anche all'epoca e tutt'oggi è
uno dei centri di eccellenza tra le
biotecnologie bioingegneria e poi ho
preso un master in management perché la
mia idea era quella che il mio
contributo alla salute delle persone
2 a tradursi in un percorso di scouting
di nuove tecnologie scoperta di nuove
tecnologie per fare in modo che queste
tecnologie arrivassero nelle mani dei
pazienti che ne avevano bisogno
e fu così che a 26 anni fonda la mia
prima società questa società portò in
italia come diceva marco prima il primo
sequenziamento del genoma intero non
soltanto una parte ma abbiamo eletto per
la prima volta l'intero genoma di un
paziente e lo scopo di questa società
era proprio quello di individuare e
diagnosticare le malattie genetiche dei
pazienti questa la rivoluzione perché
fino a pochi anni fa non c'era la
possibilità di vedere tutto genoma dei
pazienti ma si vedevano solo dei piccoli
pezzi con questa nuova tecnologia che
non abbiamo inventato noi però abbiamo
portato in italia abbiamo siamo riusciti
a fare diagnosi su decine centinaia e
ora anche migliaia di pazienti
oltre a questo test abbiamo anche
portato un'altra innovazione tecnologica
che riguarda l'analisi prenatale non
invasiva anche questo un test del dna
che nel suo piccolo ha rivoluzionato un
altro campo che a quello appunto delle
analisi del delle malattie genetiche che
possono avere i feti quando sono ancora
nella pancia della madre e abbiamo
portato una tecnologia che ha
rivoluzionato questo campo
in particolare perché si è passati da un
analisi del dna carey invasiva
l'amniocentesi la villocentesi che sono
due tecnologie tuttora utilizzate ma che
hanno un forte impatto sulla salute del
figlio un forte impatto potenziale sulla
salute del figlio e sulla salute della
madre
in particolare la mia gente le video
centesi sono due test che hanno un
rischio aborto in cerca d'un per cento e
con questa nuova tecnologia invece noi
siamo riusciti a analizzare il dna del
feto con un semplice prelievo di sangue
quindi questo completamente annullato
tutto quello che è il rischio legato
alla diagnosi di patologie genetiche
delle gestanti poi mio percorso si è
voluto affronto le altre società una di
queste si focalizza invece su
l'analisi e la personalizzazione della
cura oncologica quindi i malati di
tumore in italia ci sono circa 200 mila
persone ogni anno che muoiono di tumore
sono circa 500 giorno è un numero
veramente impressionante
ma la buona notizia è che le nuove
tecnologie stanno aiutando a
personalizzare sempre più la cura ed
aiutare i pazienti a sopravvivere di più
a queste patologie in particolare una
cosa è stata scoperta a pochi anni fa è
che non tutti i tumori sono uguali non
tutti i tumori al cervello sono uguali
tra una persona e l'altra non tutti i
tumori ai polmoni sono uguali da una
persona all'altra è così per tutti
tipologie di tumori e questo cambio di
paradigma cioè e individuare quelle che
sono differenze di tumore tra una
persona e un'altra ha permesso di
sviluppare tecnologie terapie e farmaci
nuovi che danno una speranza in più e
che sono molto più efficaci di quelli
che venivano utilizzati una volta e chi
invece non discriminavano tra paziente e
paziente ma discriminavano solo tra un
organo o l'altro che erano appunto il
focolare del tumore e quindi se passate
a quella che si chiama medicina
personalizzata farmacogenomica c'è un
farmaco potenzialmente addirittura per
ogni persona e questo è stato appunto
un'altra pietra miliare un'altra
tecnologia veramente innovativa che
abbiamo portato qui in italia quindi
come capite cioè un fil rouge no che
segue tutto questo percorso individuare
nuove tecnologie che sono sviluppati dei
migliori ricercatori al mondo dal dagli
stati uniti all'asia all'europa e
portarle 2 questa tecnologia non è
ancora arrivata una missione semplice le
inventiamo quasi nulla
facciamo poche invenzioni sono un po che
ricerca e sviluppo però facciamo una
cosa invece molto importante cioè
portiamo le tecnologie laddove non ci
sono sempre con questa società bp ci
occupiamo di medicina personalizzata in
oncologia
abbiamo portato un'altra tecnologia di
cui vorrei parlarvi ed è la biopsia
liquida una biopsia liquida non è altro
che un altro esame del sangue non
invasivo come quello di cui abbiamo
parlato prima per le donne incinta che
permette di individuare quelle che sono
le caratteristiche del tumore
all'interno del sangue della persona
stessa quindi con un esame assolutamente
non invasivo è possibile andare
individuale quelle sono le
caratteristiche del tumore è la cosa
principale che ha fatto questo tipo di
tecnologia è permettere di
migliorare i pazienti che sono stati
operati e sono stati curati dal tumore
per verificare se ci saranno poi un tra
un ritorno della patologia del paziente
quindi le metastasi e ritorno appunto
della patologia
un'altra cosa che è il futuro non è
ancora realtà ma arriverà fra pochissimi
anni e l'utilizzo la biopsia liquida
invece come strumento di prevenzione e
la prevenzione è la cosa più importante
è veramente per la salute di tutti
quanti noi è molto più importante
prevenire che curare la medicina fino ad
oggi è stata una medicina
interventistica facevamo diagnosi e poi
cercavamo di di curare la persona per
questa patologia che è stata
diagnosticata ora adesso invece
soprattutto nell'ambito dei tumori
il futuro è quello di cercare di
utilizzare le biopsie liquida quindi un
esame del sangue per individuare le
caratteristiche personali del tumore del
dna del tumore in ogni paziente e lo
faremo non soltanto sulle persone che
hanno già una diagnosi di tumore che
sono già state malati magari sono già
state curate ma anche e soprattutto per
le persone sane che potrebbero
svilupparlo
ricordiamo che circa un terzo dei
decessi che avvengono i paesi
occidentali tra cui anche l'italia sono
proprio dovuti a questa patologia
quindi riuscire a individuare in fase
molto precoce molto iniziale una
patologia importante pericolosa come il
tumore chiaramente aiuterà ad allungare
tantissima sopravvivenza perché già oggi
possiamo curare moltissimi tumori purché
questi vengano diagnosticati individuati
in fase molto precoce
la prossima sfida all'ultima sfida che
mi ha visto coinvolte l'ultima
tecnologia che mi ha visto coinvolto è
quello dell'analisi dei big data in
ambito sanitario
in tantissimi ambiti sentiamo parlare
spesso di big data
cosa sono i big data fondamentalmente
sono dati che coinvolgono moltissimi
parametri e che nel caso dell'ambito
sanitario vanno dalla same molecolare
dell'esame del sangue all'esame del dna
ma non solo anche l'esame delle
i costi legati a tutto quello che è la
sanità all'uso dei farmaci e quant'altro
e lo studio di questi dati ci permette
di vedere dall'alto quello che è la
performance e del pattern i modelli del
servizio sanitario che ci sta curando e
analizzando questo guardando quale
ospedale fa quale tipo di sanità
comunque qualità riusciamo sicuramente a
dare delle ricette che migliorino il
servizio di queste persone che mai le
persone vengono curate in queste
strutture
vi faccio una domanda voi sapete qual è
il fattore che attualmente è il più
predittivo l'informazione che più
predittiva per la salute di una persona
e per la lunghezza della solita qui
avete un diciamo un piccolo piccolo
suggerimento il codice postale ad oggi
uno dei parametri che meglio ci dice
quale sarà la lunghezza della nostra
vita e quale sarà il livello di cura a
cui potremo avere accesso è il codice
postale perché perché il codice postale
ci può dare informazioni sul nostro
livello socio economico sul nostro
livello di istruzione su la tipologia di
strutture sanitarie la qualità delle
strutture sanitarie a cui possiamo avere
facilmente accesso e questo cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che la sanità non ha la
stessa qualità e non dà la stessa
aspettativa di vita e la stessa qualità
di cura in giro per il mondo ci sono dei
paesi ci sono delle città ci sono dei
quartieri che hanno livello sanitario
un'aspettativa diversa molto diversi
rispetto a città con semplicemente se un
codice di avviamento postale è diverso e
questo è una cosa che io ei miei
collaboratori stiamo cercando di
cambiare e come lo facciamo con quello
che ho detto prima individuando nuove
tecnologie e portandole alle persone in
tutto il mondo perché la nostra missione
finale e questa
questa è una copertina del times di
qualche mese fa che dice questo bambino
un bambino nato oggi potrebbe
potenzialmente vivere fino a 140 anni
come applicando le tecnologie che oggi
sono già disponibili ma sono disponibili
solo in certi centri sono nei centri più
sviluppati e innovativi e la nostra
missione la missione nella mia vita è
stata proprio quella cercare di portare
la tecnologia
comunque partendo dal nostro paese e nel
resto del mondo per cercare di vivere
più a lungo in salute e soprattutto
essendo molto saggi e felici anche da
vecchio grazie